I'm wearing ill-fitting men's shirt from
H&M times river fashion hi guys my name
is grace Helbig if you didn't know now
you know your life is different now the
MTV Movie Awards happened over the
weekend so it's time to review the
clothing fabrics that covered the skins
of the human you know a lot of people
ask me if I'm a writer for these videos
and I think the answer is obvious I
[Music]
don't talk to people let's get into the
review garage EP ensign you look like a
Jetson
you also look a little bit like you
could be my mom's friend that's going
through a hard time in life and decided
to take some like salsa dancing classes
and then at like the dance recital all
the other like middle-aged women were
wearing these like kind of decent
dresses from Joyce Leslie and you just
showed up in this no one was like hah
but still like your cha-cha is kind of
mediocre but you look right every
Steinfeld and you'll serve mmm
steam coming up with teapots you got a
little teacup or like a Faberge egg I
got a chance on the Seventeen magazine
and found out that cutouts are very cool
and the lower half of your dress looks
very much like the opening credits of an
MGM movie in which the Lions face would
be directly at your cooter back out Ron
you look like the most handsome boy band
member that I hired to paint my living
room it was like if I was using
TaskRabbit in Los Angeles and I just
asked someone to come help with paint my
bathroom when you showed up because
you're an out-of-work actor that also
just needs to make money on the side and
I'd be like it just arrived on me with
this I actually I forgot my arms you can
do this so you if you just want to sit
in the Sun in my advantage point I'll so
pay I'll pay you you guys no task
gravity it's not enough for service if
any of you were concerned and service in
which you can hire people to help you
with like menial tasks that you can't do
alone which exactly look at that's good
Allison Williams you look cute you look
like you are a classy Las Vegas cocktail
waitress I like to going to Laguna
beaches prom your dress is very
reflective which I don't need in this
video I'm not trying to reflect on any
of my insecurities I'm only trying to
project my insecurities so moving on Jay
Mitchell oh wow
never wondered what I sound like in the
bedroom pretty close to that I like all
the cutouts so we're seeing like all the
good bits and not all the whoops it's as
our technical fashion terms in case you
felt like an idiot some might say we're
seeing all the good scam in normal a bad
sin seeing a good part of the ribcage
and not the bad part of the vaginal maze
we're seeing all the appropriate flesh
and not all the nipples is lots of terms
and fashion and I'm just here to educate
Adam Devine he was the host of MTV Movie
Awards Neil's great I can't tell exactly
what's on your student if it's some sort
of like dusty camouflage or like you
decided to run a Tough Mudder before you
got to hosting the event but you
submitted on time and you look great and
those shoes make me nervous because
they're gonna get Terry so I guess I got
a delivery because Mimi and I are here
in New York to do this kind of fancy
event tomorrow and that means Italian
with this we had to get some stuff to
wear that fell appropriate for the event
you needed another reason that I was
qualified to do these fashion reviews
Cara Belgium and gels devilish ain't
deviled egg here's the deal I love Karen
Elvis just egg because she always keeps
you guessing on the red carpet she never
plays it safe and she just continues to
this and I love that also a Lokar of new
shaved head
I mean her natural resting face was so
fierce looking that it intimidated me
and now that she looks like a deviled
egg I am frightened because they destroy
my digestive system but I keep trying to
be friends with them what a parallel
zendaya all the system you're in school
you're like a Mary Tyler Moore haircut
going with a very
again ghillie suit inspired dress why do
you look like the lady who lunches in
the forest hidden under a bunch of mom
so that you won't be seen by the
wildlife cute
ideally foods if you didn't know is a
moss-covered suit that hunters can wear
so they're not detected by other animals
in the wilderness
I own one Vanda and I are practically
like the same person it's getting crazy
Noah Cyrus
you have no cosplay okay crispy net red
latex are you kidding me this is bunkers
are some headlines and stuff people
didn't like this look but it's red latex
are you going to wear red latex it takes
big old balls to wear a red latex to an
event huge ball mass is ball mega ball
inflamed all this is very excited again
meets the coating on the outside of a
baby Bell cheese and I love both of
those things
therefore I loved it Vera Abrams okay
Camila Cabello wow thank you this is
like a sexy Easter outfit that's very
Jersey hair and if you get to eat it
this award show you already have a
built-in bib this is very like 12 year
old finally gets the okay from mom to
dress sexy for the dance and this is how
she does it jingler limited to short to
forever 21 and I'll watch out it's her
first time holding the clutch I want the
net clutch one singular lipgloss but she
still needs a clutch nearly Bobby Brown
okay I haven't watched the speech yet
because Millie won and she cried
apparently and I don't want to watch it
yet because I have to at this point I'm
very tired lately I have to pick and
choose the times in which I want to cry
oh I love this outfit I want to wear it
every day of my life to everything this
is very 11:00 in West world and if you
haven't seen stranger things or west
world just know that that was a great
reference Rebecca Black don't you look
like a witch doctor turned Minnie Mouse
into a human girl that one is to be
misfiring pop singer will end with
so very very obsessed to a kind of
emotionally stunting place with sporty
spice kill the boy some stranger things
whoa Millie looks different as steve
aoki guys whoever is your stylist should
be hired for every person because they
do a great job you guys look young and
fun and hip and cool but then you've
been at the office looking regal and
elegant and super sophisticated because
I'm like just a fun old baby ad with
Steve Aoki Emma Watson oh god I love
Emma Watson you look like a beautiful
ice dancer and I don't hate it or you
look like you went through the Udo 62 65
year old women salsa dancing recital
that taraji was that you just grabbed
the scarf from one of the other women
there and you wrapped it around yourself
and that you and taraji just cha-cha all
the way to them TV rewards together cute
GG gorgeous oh my god yes I've seen some
photos on Instagram and girl you looked
amazing this is very I Dream of Jeannie
meets
I'm actually the lamp from Aladdin I
love it it also looks like your boobs
are too like sexy cat eyes and they're
just crying fringe if that ain't a
metaphor it's not it's actually not at
all okay that was my review of the MTV
Movie Awards red carpet fashions let me
know in the comments down below who is
your favorite look of the night and let
me know what events or award shows or
other things I should review the
fashions of give this video a thumbs up
if you liked it and subscribe to this
YouTube channel don't get to hit the
subscribe button and put if there's like
a little bell button somewhere hit that
because that will give you a
notification when their videos go up
make them Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes I don't know this kind of
looks like a deodorant commercial where
it's like sexy girl gets on the carpet
and then I'll send this like silky
sparkly manifestation of bad underarm
odor starts creeping its way out until
it starts making itself known and then
she freaks out and runs back to her limo
and then when she gets an early most
thankfully or like
well-placed and like more attractive
than normal limo drivers with a much
better personality than many limo
drivers just the charismatic limo driver
your casual character medical imagery
happens to have a tiny child sized
deodorant burner and she's able to keep
that silky terrible odor at bay and go
back to the carpet and do this does if
you want to talk about me writing a
commercial for your guys I am available